الى المقصود من قراراته الجديده اقر سياسه
جديده في ما يخص تعليق الحسابات يحتار اذا
مالك تويتر الجديد فبموجب القرار الذي
سيبدا في فبراير تفتح منصه تويتر الباب
امام مستخدميها للطعن على تعليق حسابهم
على الموقع ليتم تقييمها من اجل اعاده
تفعيل الحساب اوضحت شركه انه لن يتم تعليق
الحسابات على المنصه الا في حاله
الانتهاكات الجسيمه او المستمره والمتكرره
فانتهاكات الجسيمه التي تحدثت عنها منصه
تشمل الانخراطه في محتوى او نشاط غير
قانوني وتحريض او التهديد بالعنف او الاذى
والمشاركه في المضايقات التي تستهدفه
مستخدمين اخرين وغير ذلك
[موسيقى]
تويتر
لتعليق حساباتهم ماذا اهميه ذلك
بطبيعه الحال الموضوع كثير مهم وخاصه بعض
الاجراءات اللي اخذ بطرد عدم كثير كبير من
الموظفين وخلى الموضوع ايقاف الحسابات
يكون اكتر اوتوميتد لانه هذا الموضوع بخلي
انه ممكن كثير حساباتي توقف بشكل اذا بدك
اغير صح او لاسباب غير صحيحه فهذا الموضوع
بخليهم اذا بدك في المحل معين يرجع اعتراض
ويرجعوا
حساباتهم بس في ملاحظه كانت عندكم
بسبب انه بيعتبر انه هذا المحتوى هذا ما
يخلي هذا المحتوى يوصل وهذا الموضوع اذا
هل بس سيدي تم استخدامها بشكل سلبي
المحتوى يوسف
فهذا الموضوع
قلتم انه سيخفي المحتوى يعني اذا حاد اي
حدا تجاوز همم شروط تويتر سيخفي محتواه او
كذلك الحد من وصول التغريدات او مطالبات
المستخدم بازاله التغريده قبل ان يقوم
بالتعليق الحساب كيف رايتم هذه الاجراءات
اذا بدك عدل يعني اذا هو مضبوط بده يحط
المعايير العادي يتحكم بهذا الموضوع اكيد
ما هو حر بس اذا بده يتحكم بهذا الموضوع
سيكون اذا بدك سياسيا وهو اعلم انه هو
معطل سياسي معيا ضد سياسه ثاني بامريكا
مثلا يعني هم جمهوريين ضد الديمقراطيين
يتم استخدامها لاسباب سياسيه لاسباب
العلاقه بالبسنس او بغيرها ممكن يكون عم
بيحجب
نفسه بقى تكون قاعد بيمثل المحتوى للعالم
رهيب
ليش انتهاكات همم المشاركه في مضايقات
تستهدف مستخدمين الاخرين الثاني التحريض
او التهديد العنف الاذى هذا مفهوم لكن
الانخراط في محتوى او نشاط غير قانوني مين
اللي يحدد همم المحتوى الغير القانوني في
هذه الحاله
هذا السؤال الاهم نحن في عنا نقطتين
بيحددوا مين هو المحتوى الغير قانوني اول
شيء لانه تويتر هو منصه تابع لامريكا
فبيخضع على الاولين الامريكيين مثلا اي
مواضيع ما مقصوده يعني مسلفتها مثلا
امريكا ارهابيه
هذه الملتزم حسب الالوان
هي حسب سياسه المناصه وهذا الموضوع
او يدخل الموضوع